hey everyone it's your girl Abby Sharpe
from Abby's kitchen first of all I want
to say thank you so much for the
overwhelming support that you guys
showed me after my pregnancy
announcement I don't know why I was like
nervous to talk about this I was also
really excited but I just think in light
of everything that I went through and
all the challenges that I faced your
support means so much to me and I'm so
excited to really bring you along on
this journey with me through this
pregnancy but a lot of you had actually
asked me about my protocol and
everything that I did to get pregnant
and to stay pregnant now huge disclosure
before we get into this this video is
definitely for education and really
entertainment purposes only I am not
recommending that anybody do this
protocol at all obviously anyone's
infertility protocol would be highly
dependent on their blood work and their
diagnosis and in fact taking one or more
of these supplements could potentially
depending on your case actually reduce
your chances of getting pregnant so
please always be working with your
doctors and fertility team to find the
best protocol for you okay so quick
little fertility recap this was not
natural conception this baby was
conceived via IVF or in vitro
fertilization and the reason for that is
because I have PCOS and I don't ovulate
and one of the major issues I was having
with my previous embryo transfers and
pregnancy losses was that I had thin
uterine lining and we don't know exactly
why that happened but it is speculated
that this may have been caused by me
being on the pill for so long but that
is a whole other video so if you're
interested in that leave me a comment
below and maybe I will dive more into
that later but basically the uterine
lining is really important that's what
you shed when you have a period every
single month and the uterine lining
needs to get nice and thick and fluffy
for the embryo to implant into it and
stick to it
so that
can have a viable pregnancy and in ivf
most doctors won't even transfer an
embryo unless you have at least eight
millimeters thickness in your uterine
lining and that's just going to help
ensure the best chances of actually
conceiving so let's first talk about
what I did before my embryo transfer to
help prepare myself for pregnancy
first of all pre transfer let's talk
supplements number one of course
prenatal and I started taking I mean I
was always really taking prenatal I
don't think I even stopped because I
went from basically breastfeeding to
then immediately trying to get pregnant
and even when you're breastfeeding you
should be continuing with your prenatal
supplement and I think I've mentioned
this in another video but I know my
nutrition professors always used to say
if you are sexually active and you are
if child bearing age you should be on a
prenatal vitamin just because to
safeguard against whoopsies and
accidentally getting pregnant and we
know how important that is for both for
mom but also for baby for protecting
against neural tube defects and I do
often recommend that when possible you
choose a prenatal vitamin that has
methylfolate instead of just folic acid
and the reason for that most supplements
have folic acid because it's a more
stable form but then we our body has to
convert that folic acid into the active
methylfolate and it's estimated that up
to 60% of women actually have a gene
variant that hinders this conversion and
I don't know if for sure if I have this
gene variant most people don't know
however this gene variant is linked with
PCOS and miscarriage loss and for that
reason I just felt like it was safer to
make sure that I was getting that
methylfolate
in my supplement okay so next was NAC or
n-acetylcysteine there is some evidence
to suggest that NAC use is helpful for
recurrent miscarriage and pregnancy loss
so this was a must for me I also is
taking l-arginine a pretty high dose
actually because that's what's being
used in the literature but l-arginine is
a amino acid that operates in the
nitrous-oxide pathway to kind of promote
blood vessel dilation and improve blood
flow so this was really for my thin
uterine lining
and there is some evidence to suggest
that l-arginine is helpful for those who
are poor responders in ivf particularly
those with the thin uterine lining like
me
next was vitamin E this one was really
important because there is evidence to
suggest that vitamin E supplementation
could increase the endometrial thickness
in half of the women who were taking it
which is pretty good outcomes also
vitamin D I mean I think most people
especially here in Canada can benefit
from a vitamin D Suleman so this is
something I take all year round but for
infertility particularly it is really
great because there is evidence to
suggest that it may benefit some of the
metabolic parameters in PCOS and there
is also evidence to suggest that having
optimal blood levels may help increase
IVF success rates and pregnancy rates in
general so I don't know vitamin D really
is such an important vitamin that we
really should not be overlooking okay
I'm almost done that we have Omega
threes again this is something I take
all year round I think most people can
benefit from taking an omega-3
supplement especially if you don't eat a
ton of fatty fish but there's also some
research to suggest that supplementing
with omega-3 supplements may increase
the likelihood of a successful pregnancy
in women undergoing IVF so that was
great also melatonin a low-dose
melatonin I mean obviously I was loving
that I had an excuse to take this
because I wasn't sleeping well so that
was helping me but also there is some
evidence that it helps with fertility as
well particularly that it can improve
the implantation rates for women who are
struggling with PCOS so that was another
reason for me to take the melatonin and
then finally was my magnesium calm
supplement which is like a little powder
he put some water and I would just take
a shot of it before bed basically and
this was just first sleep not
necessarily a fertility supplement per
se however I do strongly believe that
getting better sleep was really integral
to the success of this transfer cycle
and I just know that you know all of the
the cycles that didn't work or ended up
being pregnancy losses those were the
cycles
I was in like the pits of my deep dark
insomnia so I mean it's totally
anecdotal but that was my experience and
I just knew I had to get my sleep under
control but basically magnesium
activates the parasympathetic nervous
system which helps to kind of make you
feel calm and relaxed
it also binds GABA receptors which helps
to quiet down some nerve activity so it
does help to kind of made me feel a
little bit more calm and relaxed right
before bed and I still do take it okay
so now let's talk about some of the
lifestyle things that I was doing
starting with acupuncture so like I said
my main issue is that I have thin
uterine lining and there is some
evidence to suggest that are you doing
poppy
there is some evidence to suggest that
acupuncture may help with pregnancy
rates embryo transfer rates and help
with the the uterine lining but for me
more than anything I just feel like it
was almost like forced meditation
because you're kind of stuck there
hostage well like for at least a half an
hour well there's things in you know
your hands so you can't even like go on
your phone
right we're so used to just always bike
okay if I'm just having to do nothing
then I'll just like scroll through my
phone you couldn't even do that so I
really had to relax and it forced me to
relax in an otherwise stressful process
okay next was my sleep and stress
management strategies so my doctor just
kept telling me over and over again
because obviously I was so stressed you
kept saying Abby you know stress does
not impact your your outcomes here your
chances of getting pregnant probably
telling me that as a way to make me feel
less stressed but I still inherently
just knew instinctively that my stress
and my lack of sleep was obviously not
helping the cause so I really made an
extra effort especially this last
transfer round to to get my stress and
sleep under control and I obviously made
a whole video about some of these
strategies that helped my insomnia so
you can check that out right here but
some of the things I was doing included
taking on you know not working
or really even doing any screen time
before bed taking on fewer projects
taking more downtime and also ultimately
doing a lot of therapy and then finally
gentle exercise so for this cycle I
really did try to tone down my exercise
regime
I stopped any cardio I dropped my
weights down that I was using so let's
say I was bench pressing like 25 pounds
I took it down to like 15 which was
really hard for me at first because I
was like this is so easy and boring and
I got like getting anything out of this
but it was still really nice to move my
body now I'm probably doing like 20
pounds and I'll stay here for the rest
of my pregnancy not expecting or wanting
to like get stronger or anything like
that and then I'll pick it up when I
feel ready postpartum but I really
didn't want to get my heart rate up too
high and I also did not want to spike my
cortisol as high cortisol has been
associated with infertility so there's
that - okay so let's talk about diet
here now there are a bunch of like
Chinese medicine recommendations for
fertility especially with like thin
uterine lining so people are
recommending me to eat lots of red foods
because it helps with blood flow but
honestly I didn't find any research to
back any of these things up so I didn't
want to stress myself out unnecessarily
by like making all I can elite red foods
so the only thing I really did
concentrate on for the most part was no
caffeine I didn't even have chocolate I
also cut out alcohol actually for this
last cycle but not even yeah not even
any chocolate like maybe a bike here
there but really not much more than that
and a lot of women out there can have
chocolate I mean not just talked about
any caffeine without any issues in early
pregnancy but there is evidence to
suggest that having more than 200
milligrams is associated with double the
miscarriage risk and for someone who was
already clearly prone to that I was not
willing to take that risk
also one of the drugs I'm on prednisone
causes eggs
and insomnia and I really did not want
to perpetuate those side effects the
other thing that I I guess I really was
concentrating on was just eating enough
food because again I didn't want to
spike my cortisol and under fueling is
something that can is linked to to
higher levels of cortisol so for me I
was just really focusing on lots of
healthy snacks lots of healthy fats at
all my meals and just lots of nourishing
comfort foods okay so now let's get into
the hard stuff my drugs okay so first of
all is the estrogen patches and
injections so most people will have to
do either patches or estrogen
suppositories vaginal suppositories is a
way to help thicken the uterine lining
and because my uterine lining was so
temperamental I also had to do
injections this transfer round which I
had never done before I had always just
done either patches or suppositories and
clearly it really didn't do that much so
we added in those injections and that
seemed to help progesterone is another
thing that really is a non-negotiable
for IVF so you do suppositories so I did
those three times today and then
injections every other day and the
injections are in the old bum thank you
to my nurse husband for doing that every
morning for me but basically you start
the progesterone what you're lining
reaches the desired thickness and it
really just helps to kind of like
stabilize the lining and prevent
pregnancy loss so in fact some women
even if they're not undergoing IVF will
take progesterone in the first trimester
just as a way to kind of stabilize
things and keep things nice and steady
and good okay
next was vaginal viagra yes you heard me
right I remember when I went to the
pharmacy one time to pick this up and
the pharmacist was like sorry ma'am I
hate to do this but like can you tell me
what this is for exactly I've never seen
instructions to give viagra vaginally as
a suppository and of course I explained
it to him but basically viagra
increases blood flow to the nether
regions and since a uterine lining
requires good blood flow the theory is
that the viagra's if given vaginally as
the suppositories is going to help with
that blood flow and thicken the uterine
lining and actually there is some pretty
good evidence that it does work for some
women now I will say that my my cycle
before this one which was like super
long and drawn out
it used vaginal viagra and it did not
work for me but it who knows what
exactly went wrong but one thing I
figured out in retrospect was that with
the failed cycle I just went to the
regular pharmacy and got the
prescription filled there and they gave
me just the regular stereotypical blue
pills that men usually take and I just
feel like they were never actually
dissolving and absorbing properly this
is gonna be a total TMI but basically
everything all the time I would insert
to one of these blue pills vaginally I
would like feel up there a bunch of
undissolved pills and I was like am i
spending like $100 a day on this drug
and it's not even absorbing or
dissolving then with this cycle that
actually did work I went to the
compounding pharmacy and they had
actually compounded me proper vaginal
suppositories that were like clear and
they dissolved and it was like super
easy and I mean that wouldn't ended up
working so I don't know just a little
pro tip tip if you get prescribed
vaginal viagra for infertility or thin
uterine lining I don't know maybe try to
go to a compounding pharmacy to get an
actual suppository okay next was
low-dose aspirin
so aspirin is a vasodilator so it
increases blood flow to the uterus which
in turn can help thicken theater and
lining and there is research to suggest
that adding low-dose aspirin to your
protocol may help to thicken the up the
lining and also increase pregnancy rates
so that was something that we had in my
protocol pretty much from the beginning
once we realized that the line was an
issue
and then finally I took the
antihistamine CPP a protocol so this
protocol requires you to take ten
milligrams of prednisone ten milligrams
of claritin and 20 milligrams of pepcid
every single day and the theory is that
one of the reasons why we see recurrent
miscarriage is that the the uterus is
natural killer cells attack the foreign
fetus and so these drugs actually down
regulate the immune system in the hopes
that the fetus will be spared now there
is some medium quality evidence to
suggest that this protocol does work and
a lot of fertility clinics do say
anecdotally that it works for a lot of
women so that's why we decided to give
it a go
however I will say it's not easy it was
my least favorite drug to have to take
prednisone is evil and I mean ten
milligrams is not even a super high dose
so I have I can't even imagine having to
take a clinical like like IBD type of
dose like 50 or 60 milligrams because 10
milligrams alone made me feel super
loopy and bloated and just kind of crazy
also super anxious so hated that but
again kitchen sink approach I was
willing to do anything okay so finally
let's talk about the procedures that
helped me get pregnant so first of all
obviously IVF we did IVF with XE and PGS
testing for this round and XE is
basically where unlike natural
fertilization which occurs when you have
the petri dish with the egg and you add
some sperm in there and the sperm fight
it out to get to the AEGON and fertilize
the egg XE is where they find the best
sperm they put them in a hook I'm
decided to boy put the sperm into a
needle of sorts or a syringe and they
insert it into the egg and it kind of
like forces it to to fertilize so we did
XE and then we did what we call PGs
testing so it's a genetic screening
where they biopsy
little bit of the tissue of the
fertilized embryo after it's well
unfortunately we froze our eggs had to
saw them and then they biopsied them and
then they froze them again so basically
that will help to rule out any any of
the embryos that are just not
genetically competent and are therefore
more likely to result in a miscarriage
or a chemical pregnancy so we did that
next was my intro lipid infusions which
I did once before my transfer and then
once after a positive pregnancy test
so in this procedure basically I was
hooked up in an IV in my arm for three
hours as they slowly pumped what was
basically mayonnaise into my vein but
seriously like the ingredients in the
bag were soy oil egg yolks glycerin and
water
so basically Mayo and definitely not
begin but basically this procedure is
also based on the theory of the natural
killer cells attacking the fetus and the
thought is that these fatty acids help
to kind of stave off the natural killer
cells and spare the fetus essentially
there aren't any really big randomized
control trials that have looked into
using intra lipid infusions however some
early trials have been really promising
but what we know is that not every woman
is going to benefit from inter lipid
infusions those that are most likely to
benefit are those with autoimmune
diseases rheumatoid arthritis and Dmitry
osis and those like me with recurrent
miscarriage and finally was the uterine
dilation now this my friends was the
magic procedure that we all believed was
what got me pregnant this is what made
all of the difference so I remember my
doctor sitting me down and being like
Abby are you ready to go into like
uncharted like non evidence-based
territory with me and I was like yes I
am desperate take me there I will do
anything at this point and he explained
to me that in his clinical experience a
lot of women who've been on the pill for
a very long period of time were
breastfed for a long period of time
their estrogen is so levels are
suppressed but their uterus kind of like
curtains up and shrivels up I mean I'm
sure that's not the actual technical
process of what actually is going on but
that was how he's trying to explain to
it to me in mid and like laypersons
terms basically and so he likened it to
having like a thin eggshell coating
around the uterus that made it very
difficult if not impossible for any
estrogen including the the kind of
synthetic estrogen that they were giving
me as drugs to penetrate the uterus to
thickened the uterine lining so he was
thinking about this experience as you
know those days where you have a muscle
knot and you go in there for her deep
tissue massage and they're really
massaging in there to try to get the
blood flow back to the to the muscle and
he thought hmm what if I could massage
the uterus to help stimulate blood flow
and therefore thicken the uterine lining
well he obviously wasn't going to stick
his whole hand in me and manually
massage my uterus so what he did instead
or his his theory was I can put a
balloon up into your uterus and pump the
balloon up and essentially break that
shell and then of course you'd go on to
have a normal typical transfer cycle
taking estrogen to thicken the lining
but without any research having been
done on this this procedure of course
this is just something he made up he had
done this on eight other women all of
which had very similar stories that I
had so thin uterine lining recurrent
miscarriages and it worked on seven out
of eight of those women so I didn't even
have a think about it I was like yes
sign me up I will absolutely be in for
this and guess what
spoiler alert folks it worked like it
actually thing worked my lining which in
any other scenario would never get past
six millimeters I actually got to eight
millimeters without any kind of extended
drug protocol and that was the cycle
that gobby pregnant and have
to be pregnant it literally felt like a
miracle I'm still in absolute on and
he's since told me he's going to work on
publishing these findings so that people
around the world infertility clinics can
start to utilize this so incredible
miraculous procedure now how was your in
dilation in general well the worst part
for me was that I had to take
antibiotics for two weeks before the
procedure just as a safeguard in case
and in against infection and that was
pretty horrible because they may be
really really sick but the procedure
itself they actually put me completely
out for because I assumed it would have
been really painful otherwise so I
didn't feel a thing
and afterwards I think I just felt some
like mild cramping and like mild
discomfort so really wasn't bad it also
only cost me five hundred dollars which
I know for some of you might be thinking
well that is five hundred dollars too
much but in the grand scheme of IVF it's
like I don't know a few days worth of
medications so it was absolutely worth
taking the jump okay so that was before
transfer and then what did I do after
transfer so after the embryo transfer I
had to eliminate a lot of the
supplements that it's not that they're
not necessarily safe it's just that we
don't have any evidence to prove that
they're safe so obviously they're just
it's just not echoed in pregnancies so
at that point I was down to just taking
my prenatal supplement NAC which I
reduced to 500 milligrams a day vitamin
D Omega 3 and my magnesium okay so my
drug protocol after transfer and after
you know in those early days of
pregnancy or continuing my progesterone
and estrogen injections until I was
eight weeks pregnant I continued taking
the progesterone suppositories and
estrogen patches until I was 10 weeks
pregnant and then they slowly weaned me
down continued to the low dose aspirin
until I was seven weeks no normally they
would have continued this longer but I
ended up having a sub chorionic hematoma
so they just want to get me off any
blood thinners just to reduce the risk
of bleeding I also got to reduce my
prednisone
dose in half to five milligrams as soon
as I got a positive pregnancy test which
was so exciting because that was the
worst drug of all of them and then I got
to come off it completely by eight weeks
Oh hallelujah and then continued to my
pepcid until 12 weeks pregnant and
Clairton also till 12 weeks pregnant and
then I was on my own baby yeah just my
body was doing its own thing and that
felt so freeing finally how did my
lifestyle and diet change well not a
whole lot I would say that you know this
time I really had to focus on the stress
and the sleep and really continuing on
with all the work that I'd done there so
I did lots of meditations every single
day continue to avoid any heavy lifting
and any kind of heavy exercise just
doing gentle exercise walking things
like that went to therapy every single
week and really tried to make that a
priority
I also continued with acupuncture once a
week even though the points that we were
using obviously changed a little bit
since you know before transfer and after
transfer well pregnant and then finally
I've really tried to just focus when it
comes to food and diet on eating
whatever I could really tolerate because
I had really really bad morning slash
all-day sickness basically all first
trimester so I had to just really tune
in and listen to my body and figure out
what I could eat what made me feel good
what did not when I felt full I felt
full full so I had to go really really
slow so bottom line here folks if you're
still with me is that I know if you're
watching this and maybe you if you
haven't struggled with infertility in
the past you might be thinking like what
the hell I thought that you just have to
have unprotected sex and like forget
your pills for a few days and suddenly
you'll get pregnant I mean I wish it was
that easy for me nothing in motherhood
has been easy for me especially
including getting to motherhood but I
also want to acknowledge that my Road
has not been the hardest of all that's
for sure I have so many
things that I'm grateful for like like a
supportive partner and that I have
access and can afford infertility
treatments and that I'm relatively young
and I'm healthy and that I have a child
that I love and and if God forbid this
didn't work out for me I would have to
and I would find joy and and happiness
in what I have it is enough I am so
grateful for that
you know I know so many women and
couples out there who have been at this
for so so long and struggling so many
years you know they've mortgaged their
homes and they've gotten divorced out of
stress and and they still don't have a
child so yeah I know that I'm a lucky
one but my purpose with this video is
not to you know gain and garner any kind
of sympathy but rather to open up a
conversation with parents and intended
parents because nobody ever talks about
infertility and it makes it so much
harder it makes us feel so much more
isolated and alone so if you are
struggling please please reach out I am
here whether you want to email me or DM
me or leave me a comment below I will be
your sounding board I'm here to listen I
am here to offer solicited advice if
that's what you're looking for I'm just
here to you know be a supportive ear
infertility sucks and Parenthood is
really really hard so let's be a better
village together well folks I hope that
you enjoyed this video I mean it was a
lot to get through and I realized that
for those of you who hopefully don't
have to think about infertility that was
like a lot of information maybe it was
educational maybe was informational and
maybe it was interesting I don't know
but leave me a comment below I want to
hear from you about what you think about
it if you have any other questions I'm
gonna be doing AQ a about my pregnancy
and about infertility and IVF and all
that stuff any questions that you have
leave me a comment below and I will get
to them in my upcoming Q&A if
yo okay folks well in that note please
be sure to give this a thumbs up leave
me a comment subscribe to the channel
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]